news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
we're still finding out details about
this just unconscionable tragedy that
took place in beirut lebanon a couple of
days ago but we do now know enough that
we can at least say
a few things on tuesday there was
an absolutely gigantic explosion
in beirut lebanon at warehouses that
stored
highly explosive materials and the video
of this explosion looks the way that
nuclear weapons are often portrayed
in hollywood films and it was in fact
one of the largest
explosions uh essentially in
the history of humanity shock waves
smashed homes and ripped off
building facades and so far the death
toll is at 157 now just yesterday was at
1
13 so it's climbing rapidly there's
another 80 people currently unaccounted
for
ominously and more than 5 000 people
have been injured but that those those
numbers are probably a fraction of what
ultimately is going to be uncovered
tragically the shock wave spread
so far that 300 000
people were left without homes because
even miles away the impacts of this
explosion were felt
now very early in the process of trying
to figure out what happened on tuesday
donald trump wildly talked about this as
an attack
he said it looked like a bomb and to be
very clear
the reason i didn't report about this
yesterday is
i knew trump had made those assertions
with no evidence
and i didn't want to fall into similar
type of speculation
and and in fact now two days after the
event
uh it appears that what donald trump
floated was completely wrong now i'll
talk a little bit more later about him
doubling down on that but to focus on
what we do know
this appears to have been close to 3 000
tons of ammonium nitrate which can be
used in fertilizers
and in bombs which was stored for years
at the port
in beirut lebanon after being seized now
it was stored
incorrectly it appears without the
proper safety measures and so far
it looks like inaction and negligence
are to blame
for the explosion the words terrorism
attack bomb are not being used and from
what we know so far it was very
irresponsible for donald trump to use
those words
there are reports that what triggered
the explosion
was maybe related to construction or
repair work being done at a warehouse
it's still early and even that has not
yet been confirmed and it is believed
that these explosive materials had
actually been sitting there for
somewhere
in the range of six to seven years so
right at the blast
site it's complete devastation and death
in a sort of one mile radius area there
are
partial and full building collapses and
many many injuries
in a two plus mile radius from the blast
you start to go in the direction of
windows blown out
damage to buildings more on the injury
side again
and there are damaged buildings all the
way out to six
miles from the blast if you can imagine
so this is now a full-blown
disaster stone disaster zone it's a
catastrophe humanitarian groups are
trying to get into the area to provide
help other non-profits and of course
everything is in the context of
coronavirus and that is
significantly compounding the difficulty
when you have a raging pandemic any kind
of humanitarian mission becomes more
more difficult and again the the blast
is considered to be about 20 percent of
the size
of hiroshima i mean just think about the
magnitude of that
now again there is almost
no important global news story
in 2020 in which our president
does not become a reckless participant
in case in point
calling this an attack early floating
the idea of a bomb
was completely irresponsible at first it
seemed
maybe he was leaking information from a
classified briefing he had
received maybe he knew something that
had not yet been made public
he didn't he was just wildly speculating
again showing that
there's a level of irresponsibility that
he just can't get away from as president
of the united states and i'm going to
talk more later about trump doubling
down on it but instantly you have right
wingers
posting everywhere on the internet it is
an attack because of what donald trump
said the the reality is that
we probably still don't know the whole
story but that type of speculation from
a president
is childishly irresponsible and in fact
there's a long list of ammonium nitrate
explosions including here in the united
states that you might even remember
in 2013 there was an ammonium nitrate
explosion in west
texas which also led to speculation
about terrorism and attacks and bombs
that's not what it was 15 people did die
there so there can always be foul play
this is not an out of the world
unbelievable situation as it's been
reported and trump's ignorance and
irrational speculation as always
causing more problems once again